hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Endo parasitic this is a
game where you uh I think only have an
arm you don't have legs you don't have
another arm you have one arm and in a
weird way it reminded me a lot of that
game carrion where the actual like boxer
used to look a lot like a vagina but not
a lot like a vagina but kind of like a
vagina if you don't know what I'm
talking about this Probably sounds
really weird for me to open up another
game to talk about but if you know what
I'm talking about then you are nodding
your head in agreement and please back
me up in the comments because that's
exactly what happened in that thing it
was called carrion anyway this is not
that
normal
long approaching tarp
I'm in space Oh
oh
Landing guns sample delivered the
research lab
what Sam
what the hell what happened oh no I
should have done literally anything to
prevent that am I bleeding out am I
going to bleed out oh wow
oh goodness well that's one way to open
up a game ah it's like quap or grip or
gerp where do those oh hello what
what is this whatever is this my penis
oh
I didn't know that that was a thing that
could do that I didn't even know what
that was it's an iron containment breach
abandon the premise immediately
the the premise not the premises it's
just the band and the premise of this
game abandoned it all right
um
who's an iron I think I said that but
just to clarify all right I don't know
how I got here I don't know what's going
on I don't know anything about anything
I'm shockingly nimble
parasite anyway
[Music]
it can't be good this can't be good it
can be good but look at my dance moves
it can't be good it mustn't be good grab
the syringe
oh
[Music]
Daddy
oh God no
so that's just inside me now and I
didn't know that the human body was just
one big tube straight up to the brain
but wow that's ah horrible all right
good oh
no parasite detected anymore I guess I'm
cured right click to interact with it in
case of emergency the medicine will slow
the progress of parasites but will not
eradicate to keep a steady supply at all
times okay where is it at now still in
my ball sack you know it's easily
contained there some equipment was
stored in containers with simple locks
to prevent subjects from opening them
open them match the pin pairs by depth
okay I'm more concerned about subjects
so they really did tear off my limbs for
what reason
match the pin pairs
ah I see oh good
good
[Applause]
yeah yeah hello yeah yeah yeah
what's this computer in case of
containment preach all exits will be
sealed and evacuations must be funneled
through reception for screening in case
of false alarms evacuation orders can be
removed by accessing control panel in
the maintenance closet B
is this a false alarm because man stop
our research here I have to end the
evacuation orders
me my name is kite
what's my name I don't even know how to
pronounce that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this would be terrifying if you saw this
coming at you in the dark hallway which
you are this is a bathroom evacuation
protocols canceled it is safe to return
to research stations I don't think it is
I really don't think it is something
tells me it's not
[Music]
uh you okay in there am I okay in there
do I just I just coughed up
[Music]
[Music]
hi there buddy whoa hi author Ah that's
me I think lead parasitologist Nautilus
sample retrieved beginning preliminary
research sample has been sequestered to
an unmanned research facility
approximately one kilometer from the
main facility for safety purposes all
research will be conducted with a
remotely operated drones material
analysis shows a sample as a massive
pure carbon arranged in strands that
appear like a hair clumped together
there are no visible exotic materials
present in the sample that would
indicate the cause of mutation field
around the sample multiple existence
decays measurements revealed the sample
to be approximately 4.2 trillion years
old making the oldest samples I
personally encountered considering our
universe is only around 14 billion euros
years old
wait a minute
that don't add up the suggests that the
sample has either been somehow altered
to appear older than it is or that it
originates from a universe far older
than our own May null my god of
cognition of skill bless our research
okay I'm certain he's blessing me
okey dokey then oh God gotta get that
out of my lungs
no good in me
better atomy memo to all employees all
research conducted in this building is
confidential no one knows this facility
exists besides employees and members of
the research board security breaches are
punishable by Death
or dismemberment as is with the case
with me probably
well what a lovely lab I gotta get out
of here
hello no
all right this is okay that's concerning
get saved oh wait let me go back hold on
a second Cryptid coming through ah
therein lies is a problem I'll just be
on my way then God damn it's like I've
been training for this all my life I
guess you would lose some body weight
and therefore it might be easier to pull
but whatever
how's my buddy doing oh he's growing up
but he's okay oh oh oh oh what what
whoa whoa whoa
no one told me that it would be
shambling Horrors
whoa you're lucky I'm so fast
or I'm lucky anyway whatever shut up
oh this is another hallway ah well good
thing I'm so quick
all right how you doing oh you need to
not no no wait didn't I see oh like the
boy I saw I thought I saw another
syringe that I didn't get in the last
area I didn't even think about it I was
so flabbergasted a gun I won't forget
that I'm coming for you that'll help me
with the shambling [ __ ] for sure
ah oh not this time
nice thank you
how you doing buddy you stay down now
does that mean it's progressing I hope
not
I don't know how long I can keep that
out because I'm not exactly sure how
much blood I have in me
well that's a shambling horror
oh don't mind me
uh oh my God I'm a genius I'm the best
I'm the best
[Music]
man I'm speedrunning this [ __ ]
I marry you give me the gun I saw the
gun oh yes please
help me
your destiny help I could give you
all you can do now is pray
what
yeah why are you looking to me for help
oh I see
ah
man I don't know how I'm doing this with
one hand I am quite Nimble and I'm
really impressed oh God didn't mean to
do that
to get more of these well hold on a
second
that's what I thought about that
that's what I thought
what if I oh my God what's this
oh I'm gonna get so good at that I'm not
good at it right now but I'm gonna
imagine if I was good at it which is
gonna happen
wait
hold on a second
I just had an idea
wasn't there
something else probably behind that
other thing that was a shambling
monstrosity I shouldn't shoot it I
shouldn't because what I should do is I
should lock it in here
yeah come here you
come here you oh no no no oh
stupid get it oh God why
oh I'm in here now oh
look at me oh god oh there we go idiot
stupid what are you dumb yes yeah wait a
minute what did this open over here this
opened something no I got it on the
never mind I already got it well that
was a complete waste of time might as
well free this I don't want to be an
[ __ ] okay be free
wreak havoc somewhere else
and I don't know what happened to you
but I don't care
hey buddy how you doing there man I like
your growths yeah right it's like
growing my grandpa I think it's the same
kind of thing that happened it was just
weird Carbonic cilia emitting from the
body yes please
and
I gotta hold you're getting a little
high
I don't like that
all right none of space
um
something is shambling
full up there
all right so I'll come back for more
ammo when I need that which I do watch
this trick shot trick shot trick shot oh
yeah that's what we call skill out in in
out in imagine if I was really good at
this imagine okay if I could stop
coughing up blood I don't know if I'm on
like a time crunch here but
doesn't sound good
good thing those are so easy you get
down thank you
all right let's Mosey who's here
hello
anybody no
oh yep
Wham
that's what I thought
man I'm gonna need more ammo if this is
the case
it's like the uh the sniper from TF2
just side by side me with that and
you'll see it just how goddamn skilled I
am at whatever the hell I was doing
there
reloading I think is what they call it I
hear one more shambling horror
just don't know where that is terminal
uh scene how do you pronounce this C the
research board is requesting a meeting
uh regarding a concern provi recently
raised I scheduled that for tomorrow
afternoon does that work for you I do
not have time tomorrow to take the
ridiculous meetings do not schedule them
again without checking with me directly
since you clearly don't know how
important my research is I apologize sir
I will let them know to contact you for
a reschedule do not let this happen
again well I think I know why they
ripped your arms off here Lucy's I know
you'd pronounce it yeah I guess so
anybody over there
kind of hard to see from the ground
hello
somebody there boo
peekaboo
anybody I see you I saw something
I thought I saw something I did
you coming
oh oh I'm gonna sneak up on you
oh God oh God oh God nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope take some of this oh
missed
that's what I thought good thing they
are giving me some ammo
first try
all right
where else is here I hear you
I don't know if I need that I don't
whoa whoa
God I don't even need to look I'm that
good
this is weirdly satisfying the
intricacies of the gameplay like this is
a smoother gameplay than some games I've
played where you have all of your limbs
this is weirdly
this is weirdly good uh let me get the
rest of that ammo over there before I
bail maybe I'll get a bandolier or
something down the road as an upgrade
wait what's in here Hello whoa okay yep
wow
yep
oh
I did see ammo so hopefully
damn I'm good
hello that sounds different wait a
minute that sounds different
hello
hello
that's
so different
no I'm not I'm not even gonna
okay uh-huh
okay parasites making it well there's
Moro okay you know what but maybe I
don't
oh maybe I should have looked
complete
and what is that I believe the
determination protocol that will
eliminate any external interference
After exiting the decontamination tunnel
exchange any and all outside articles of
clothing for our provided sterile lab
coating proceed promptly to workstations
without abstraction or conversation
follow these same steps when departing
the research lab do not under any
circumstances reveal lab locational
research
you guys okay there he's just taking
notes is that what you're doing
oh good for you guys okay it's got to be
something where I let them all out and
then go back around right that's got to
be what it is what does this do
oh well oh whoa hey whoa why did I do
that no no no no don't do it
don't do it
oh my God oh my God get down oh my God
you opportunistic [ __ ]
Yee don't like you guys
all right
oh God no no no no no oh
oh God damn oh God damn all right
so I managed to get around them well all
right then we'll grab grab grab
okay
imagine if that was even better at that
okay
what the ammo oh there's health over
there
it's good because his parasite is being
awfully opportunistic
I could wait a bit
Maybe
hello please take any and all smoking
breaks in the reception area not the
decontamination tunnel it is
antithetical to the purpose of the
decontamination tunnel yeah you're right
about that but when did ever anyone ever
do anything correct
did that do
okay
I feel like this is um
oh
you really do want me to just go to town
on him I see
all right well you got it pal
oh
boy oh God oh God close it oh god oh
that's not what I that's not what you
want this isn't even the way for my ammo
oh God oh God all right
oh that's not good oh that's not good oh
that's not good oh that's not good who's
there who's there
no no no no no I missed okay it's fine
okay I gotta get by here's prince prince
okay made it
oh that's fan of conducing I don't know
why maybe because I only got one arm who
wants some
hello
can't tell what's alive
hit something
oh I don't like that even the corpses
are still technically moving that's
unpleasant
okay
God damn I'm still incredibly nimble
hello anybody still alive in here or not
be hello
I hate you hate all of you no who
who tell me who tell me who's
oh crap
yep
getting pretty good see that flourish of
a spin I did there
pretty cool right
yeah I'm pretty cool
okay two of you is where'd you go
getting really good at that okay was
there another one
you done are you all done
can I crawl in peace
I detected what do you mean
what do you mean
huh what if I do this
[Music]
whoa four inventory slots are you
kidding me which just fits two bullets
so I don't even know if it's four I
don't even know what I picked up
but I love it
save I just obtained someone else's
butthole and stitched it onto my own if
I even have one hello
peekaboo
oh I hear you
hello no you don't
yep
God
damn I'm good
God damn I've never gotten this good at
a game this quick never mind
missed but that's all right
okay development of preliminary vaccine
to prevent the mass fatality event
received shipping of 500 toxoplasmosis
vaccines through some trial and error
I've managed to successfully alter
toxoplasmosis vaccines that do extremely
temporary vaccines for the at secular
cerebrum parasite I'm currently unsure
of why they provide no more than a few
minutes of protection and we will be
running more procedures to make them
more effective despite sinte's claim
that they are useless we have Place
vaccines throughout the research
facilities in the case of an unlikely
break always finding ways to seem like
he's in the right I mean it kind of was
you know you can't deny this is
extremely useful
okay
yep
not enough space yeah you're right
I'll come back for it this game is I
love it it's so simplistic but at the
same time it's not right
it's in that weird middle zone of
being complexly elegant which a lot of
oh God no no no no no
oh you bastards
all right good oh boy I need a syringe
good thing that uh whatever his name was
uh who's that guy that did that thing
put all those things everywhere oh boy
nope
oh yes
control
got about it but I gotta be careful
because I don't have enough bullets to
really mess around here I got a few
though
so how did this oh no you don't oh no
you don't oh I'm faster than you
yeah
all right I don't know I wonder how this
outbreak actually occurred because you
know what these things sometimes it does
seem accidental but for all we know it
could be intentional
oh boy that's not good wait wait wait
wait wait oh God wait no no hold on
[Music]
oh boy wait wait wait
oh boy that's not good
oh boy hold on I know I've been training
for this all my life but uh I wasn't
ready
oh boy oh boy
hold on
[Music]
God damn what were you hiding back there
where are we what are you hiding big guy
I think dipping my toes in doesn't get
me infected at all surely okay so
there's just a way out over there but
what was over here
oh man oh hello hello hello hello hello
I saw someone up there
I was going by so fast I didn't even
notice there was someone up there
what's the deal
what's what's the deal what was the deal
what was up with that get down you
oh
hello
I see you watch this
oh whoops man it's really inconvenient
that I can't uh kill two in one go I
have to reload every time but I guess
it's for if you miss more than anything
they're counting on people being less
killed than me than uh
playing the kill more
okay also running our bullets it's a
good thing they also had this many
bullets in here
oh God no no
oh no
no
oh God oh God
oh God
that's too close I know there's another
one here
okay
what do these go-to
whoa oh oh it's because I I split the
bullets so of course there'd be a ah
that makes sense I don't know why I
didn't even think about that before
thank you
we're good oh but I don't wanna
hello
nope nope thank you
okay so why are these doors able to open
and close only from in here
uh parasite experiments on Lab Rats
received shipment of 12 000 at secular
cerebrum parasites and 302 Lab Rats
subjects stored in high security Wing
after exposure despite my receptionist
protest we started lab rat exposures
exposed one parasite to sample after
mutation introduced to a lab rat after
penetrating skin the parasite burrowed
to the rat's brain upon reaching it the
rain instantly mutated in a manner that
proved fatal to compare one rat was
exposed to the sample directly its
mutation pattern was found to be similar
to the infested rat
what continually exposed parasites until
one with immunity or anomaly found
experiment with ways to protect Brad
from parasite tell Lucy and reception
that progress cannot be made without
sacrifice ah good old note to self yeah
note to self-abanded morals note to self
it's all for the greater good note to
self I'm a genius note self all right
uh
wait so this oh
oh shotgun provided for Intruder safety
protocol oh my God
yes please okay so I'm gonna drop some
of these bad boys because I'm Gonna Make
Room for these okay really that's
interesting
why would that be good God are you
serious oh inventory is not never mind
never mind all right okay four bullets
two shotgun shells I'll take it yoink
what does this do what did that open
uh I should probably default to the
shotgun and use the sidearm as a backup
hello are you alive you are not alive
how are you not alive who killed you did
I kill you oh my God I killed you when
did I kill you
I don't like this
trick some justice oh God it was
unloaded
hold on
interesting
turns out it was not loaded it is now
all right
there we go okay now we're good
let's resave I got hit a bit good thing
there's another one of those things over
here
thank you all right how about now
is this just the back way that I came
I think it is
I see how did I
how did this no I don't I don't know
not gonna question it
because I have a shotgun now and I like
that
hello
anybody want a Boomstick you want a
Boomstick
what is this dude
oh no rats
why did I just have to make so many
infested rats
okay
okay
hello
oh come on I thought I had that
cute
yeah
hoop oh okay oh I see
oh God damn it well it turns out I'm not
good at video games everybody oh turns
out I'm about to die hmm
and I gotta go get those bullets
no it's not true I am good at video
games I'm gamer of the year what I say
goes in games for a whole year I've been
elected uh
oh hello
good to see you oh Advanced security wow
impressive
[Music]
okay
who wants some
anybody wants them
you want some
hello I thought they were weren't you
weren't you like right there
oh uh right the whole thing about yeah
that
yeah that okay oh God oh God oh God oh
God no hold on oh god oh wow that went
bad so fast okay hold on I'm gonna get
you I'm gonna get you I'm Gonna Get You
nope
oh it went bad so fast
okay
how did that go bad so fast I do not
know how to explain it I'm sure pravian
scene would call it ridiculous but the
day that received the shipment of
parasites I had a vision
appeared to me in my dreams and told me
the parasites were for me I didn't
understand it first I suppose I still
don't but it consumes me oh May Purity
my goddess of light and love guide me in
this puzzling Quest
yeah your God definitely not um
not any more delusional whatever that
was to make you kill everybody but you
know how it is we all have our quirks
all right in the events I go apparently
all my security clearance just doesn't
matter anymore oh god oh come on
there we go I don't know how but when I
got the shotgun I suddenly became a lot
worse
I don't know how that happened I don't
know what happened I just got terrible
at this game
I hear you
got ya
if I can stuff that in there it'd be
incredible
but I won't
be scratching you no oh
got him did I miss another path this way
let me see what's down here first
oh boy nope nope
oh boy oh
Quick Draw McGraw not quite did pretty
okay though
what was that why did it sound like I
was munching on the vaccine there the
right I mean the parasites probably
munching on my uh
ball sack and spinal column and
extremities in general
but I don't know why it sounded like
that is that the only other way to go I
guess it was
all right
well it was all fun and games for a
while with my arms ripped off and
everyone being infected with parasites
but now it's serious business and I
gotta stop goofing around I got the fate
of the world on my shoulders I think or
I guess no one knows about this research
facility so I got the fate of nothing
well I can't really bear a lot of weight
on my shoulders considering that I I
don't have legs or any weight-bearing
limbs of any kind
oh
like a little Gun Kata I mean like okay
that was extremely rude
no the shotgun to the liabilities is
because it's so goddamn long it's so
long so if they're close quarters I
really just gotta go for the pistol
because if I don't I'm gonna die every
time oh that can't have been it really I
don't if that isn't I don't have to
shoot everything I could just go buy
things because I don't know why I am
shooting everything
if I could just run by I am much faster
than you wouldn't think that being just
a bunch of uh forzo and all that but I
am I'm weirdly fast
oh I hear them oh God okay
what has Lucy been doing here so late
well I mean I know what Lucy's been
doing oh why why oh why
right it's out of ammo I forgot about
that
I remember now
the why is that it has no bullets ah
I've solved it I've solved the mystery
everybody you don't need to thank me oh
asteroid I'll thank myself I'm the only
thanks I need
okay good
okay that'll do
but I'm still not gonna try to fight
everything because I don't need to
oh God I don't like arrows I don't like
things telling me what to do this feels
bad
oh this feels extremely bad
is this full yeah
oh this feels bad whoa that's why I feel
bad everybody
all right I hope that killed him
all right I killed him okay
hello did I kill the rat too I heard him
whoa all right then
I hear the things scratching around I
feel like there's something else here
hold on bear with me a second I feel
like it
what is that
yeah I hear the scratching to the left
over here but
I don't remember there being oh
oh okay all right okay
I don't know why I needed to do that but
the scratching was bothering me
maybe if I kill everything on the
station I won't have to do some horrible
self-sacrificing thing where I blow it
all up I mean I've sacrificed three of
my limbs so full metal outcomes ain't
got nothing on me I hear you
I don't like hearing you but I hear you
okay
okay
got him
I I'm trying to resist the Earth to
instantly blind fire down the hall but
I'm doing all right
well interesting how the last one missed
oh God I'm out of bullets oh no oh I
should just pressed that button why
didn't I do that
oh God no no no not not that God you
idiot you idiot
grab your gun
oh God
oh get out of here
oh this is going horribly this is going
horribly wrong help help somebody help
anybody oh this is I don't like anything
that oh good more inventory good but I
still don't like it
okay they're full I don't know when that
got full but it's full now
okay here we go I guess oh frick
foreign
oh God put it away oh frick oh frick oh
frick oh frick oh my God
well that's unpleasant
gotta get more gotta get more oh my God
oh my God this is so weird
oh my God is this the equivalent of a
boss battle
oh God
oh God put it away
Tokyo Drift
oh man I'm just too Nimble for him
oh God I'm not nibbling up
okay where are you where are you
I hear you
got him
all right easy man not panic inducing at
all not horrifying perfectly fine good
Oh you mean I probably could have just
gone in one of these and not had to kill
all of them just ran away do you think
that there's any reason that I need to
shoot any of these at all hello doorway
sealed until ah
that there's the the reason what am I
quoting hey what am I quoting yeah what
am I quoting everybody what am I quoting
yeah I don't think there was anything
else in here
I did say there was something ah that
closed up then okay all right then on we
go I guess
I don't like that sound
because it sounds different
oh
what's going on here
what's the deal
what is the deal how many people were in
this facility
I don't have any bullets so
damn
so if there's a rat it's gonna get a
face full of shotgun
oh man I'm I don't have enough for this
well all right then
now I'm officially out of everything oh
and I'm almost out of brain good I'll
just make it I'll just scoop fast I'm
scooting fast
I'm scooting fast I'm scooting what that
look oh oh oh oh I didn't even notice
that I was running into a thing there
okay good oh good oh good oh great oh
great good good great
God my brain is almost fully parasited
what
oh God no no no no no no no you don't no
you don't Wham
okay one more for you
oh got him yeah slews I don't know what
slues means but you snooze you snooze
snooze
you snooze you snooze you snooze you
snooze you snooze you snoozeed
oh God it's just the way they shamble
he was here oh frick oh give me that oh
frick oh give me that give me that put
that there that's great okay that's bad
okay this is oh why are they all locked
why do they have to be locked why must
you lock it I've got a flare gun this is
oh it's the chain train oh it's all of
them
all right good good great great great if
I could just get a mom
I only have revolver bullets which is
unideal
oh okay snooze loose to lose a snooze I
don't know what this does but here we
freaking it's probably out yep it is
here we freaking go boom Oh all that did
was illuminate oh no no oh it roasted
you roasty toasted that was incredibly
effective okay good great I'm very happy
for that excellent excellent excellent
this is excellent it's gonna be really
difficult to be able to discern what is
what when I'm in a hurry but for now
we're doing okay me a scientist some
somehow succeeding Against All Odds with
only one arm it was a save over here
wasn't it did a nice Sprint by a save at
some point I don't know oh it was all
the way over here right
somehow I slap my hand on the save flare
gun for outdoor
we're on an asteroid what's gonna be
outdoors what do you think in the world
is going to be outdoors here nothing
nothing's gonna be outdoors here
and I have to grab that because I put
that in there and then I put this away
and then I grabbed those and then I make
sure this is loaded it is okay good and
then we go down to take care of the
other dudes down the other way because
for some reason that's what we do oh the
Hell let them all out Lucy what did you
do okay wait we're gonna do this
sure take that oh oh oh okay
holy crap oh my God oh my God I killed
all of them oh my God I'm the best
hello this is the way out please tell me
it's the way out thank you
oh good thing I'm getting more buttholes
expand my inventory
anybody else huh
flare gun in there
hello
thank you for making yourself known
flare gun can I grab that
are very useful love that okay
hypothesizing next steps ramblings the
data we were provided from other labs
research goes in depth on a singular
successful subject the subject appears
after a mass exposure and had the ideal
characteristics of both immunity and an
anomaly the subject was widely
considered to be a genius in their
Community as a mathematician and
philanthropist when the subject's
genetic family was exposed to similar
samples they perished almost instantly
make no mistake this parasite is finical
and methodical it chooses hosts to keep
alive the anomaly was imbued with
physical and mental abilities far beyond
that of a regular human the researchers
there described him as suddenly Godlike
what a gift that must be how can we
determine who it keeps alive who it
mutates in favorable ways what way is
there if not mass exposure
that's not the logical leap to make
buddy
pal whoa okay all right whoa
oh easy
easy there that's not the logical leap
to make friend why would you do why
would you do ah whatever all right I've
got this as a backup which is nice this
was reloaded yes okay good I hear you
scurrying bastards
got him nice
I hear you
nope
nope
oh God damn it oh man oh wow that was
terrible oh I can spin it
hello
don't mind me
hope that wasn't bad
probably fine
hello
oh well you were quiet
when did you guys start getting
stealthier what's the deal with that
hold on a second why are you guys being
all sneaky
oh I'm out
I don't think I got everything in that
level
but oh well
anybody else anybody
oh flare ammo
okay all right this is a little
ridiculous
oh my God
I've forgotten I did not forget amazing
incredible
I'm stunning
wait that's full interesting
well I better save that for a long line
of them because otherwise I'm going to
be in a lot of trouble
just gonna make sure I'm not gonna waste
on a single let's gather him up as best
I can
hello friend you got any more anyone
else want to join the party
anyone else
I hear you I hate that I hear you I hear
you
all right I'm unleashing the beast but
I'm not gonna do it yet oh God here we
go oh God oh God oh God grab
oh God put it away oh you did not just
do that
all right you snooze you lose oh snooze
loose I know I forgot something up here
gotta be right to the left
no really
left
ah
I know that there was a hell oh I I saw
one
didn't I
hell [ __ ] oh
no
oh God oh God wait no wait wait wait oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait this
is not fair this is not fair
this went horribly awry
stop scammering it was here oh no no no
no
am I okay
this isn't even gonna be enough because
that stupid rat got me
because that stupid rat my own Shield
breasts oh it worked oh it worked oh my
god it worked oh
you can't suggest Mass exposure to the
research board Lucy and I agree it's
unethical no doubt they will as well you
cannot jeopardize the future of a colony
civilization for your own game or can I
yeah did I uh now I know I'm not I'm not
sure what I did or if it was Lucy not
exactly sure all right rat
you're done
get done rat
oh I hear you all right
got him okay and what I have left is a
flare gun I have to use it well hello
let me just slap nope let me just slap
my hand on that
well all right then I can't sneak by
your big fat gut oh God nope not like
this not like this no this is somehow
gone so wrong
oh where where oh what
oh God what is that
ah oh my God
ah yeah but I don't oh but I oh but I
don't
uh but I
oh God I
but
oh but oh but oh but
oh what have I done
it's the end of the road for me
yeah uh yeah okay all right well anyway
that is actually all the time that I
have for this episode This is actually
very interesting though
I'm fascinated by this
it's weirdly
elegant and fun and creepy and
interesting and I want to know what
happened to this parasite thing and why
the hubris of man is never ending so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]